moi j'attends de voir le texte quand
même pardon de vous le dire comme ça
chacun sait que vos républicains nous
sommes favorables à une réforme des
retraites avec l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation et le décalage au moins 64
ans donc sur le fond n'est pas d'état
d'âme à voter une réforme qui est dans
le sens mais je suis méfiant je vous
rappelle que le président Macron avait
désigné Jean-Paul Delevoye qui pendant
18 mois avait fait des consultations
puis on nous a dit qu'il y aurait un
texte puis il y aura pas eu de texte
puis un texte qui est allé à l'assemblée
qui n'est jamais venu au Sénat on nous a
promené sur la réforme des retraites
pendant trois ans et c'est rien passé
par conséquent je suis prudent j'attends
de voir est-ce que oui ou non le
gouvernement est décidé à faire un texte
mais s'il veut faire un texte le texte
c'est pas très compliqué à faire il fait
un texte il dépose un texte de projet de
loi et on avance pour le moment on nous
dit bah vous verrez bien il y aura
peut-être un amendement dans lequel dans
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale ça n'est pas sérieux
ils ont un texte où ils ont pas de texte
le président de votre groupe LR au Sénat
Bruno Retailleau a dit qu'une telle
méthode était inacceptable ce n'est pas
tout à fait ce qu'a dit le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher regardez on va voir
son tweet il dit sur les retraites
pilier social le statu quoique plus
possible or les intentions du
Gouvernement restent confus c'est un peu
ce que vous dites aussi mais la réforme
est indispensable soit par un texte dans
l'autre projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale soit par un texte
ad-oc juste une question simple est-ce
qu'il y a une différence de ligne au
sein de la droite au Sénat non il y a
pas de différence de ligne nous nous
avons les trois dernières années déposer
des amendements d'appel puisque toute
façon il y avait une majorité absolue à
l'époque à l'Assemblée nationale donc le
gouvernement faisait ce qu'il voulait et
nous avons fait des amendements d'appel
en notamment décalant l'âge de la
retraite mais nous savons parfaitement
que il faut un texte pourquoi il faut un
texte parce que ça passera par le
Conseil d'État et surtout on aura une
étude d'impact on saura exactement quels
sont les mesures de vos amendements
d'appel comme vous dites c'est pour ça
que je dis le texte du projet de loi
franchement ça fait cinq ans qu'on
travaille dessus que le gouvernement
travaille dessus il peut faire le texte
du projet de loi en 15 jours le déposer
au Conseil d'État nous le faire voter au
mois de janvier mais maintenant qu'on en
sorte qu'on arrête ces Bizzbee parce que
moi je considère que ce cirque actuel et
on reprend la réforme parce qu'elle est
indispensable mais alors ce qu'on va
faire un amendement et on consulte et on
machin c'est encore du temps perdu ça ça
fait des années qu'on parle de cette
réforme elle est simple à faire qu'on
nous fasse un texte qu'on le dépose
qu'on en débatte et qu'on le vote
[Musique]